like we have to start getting into  meritocracy like somebody should leave  if they're not seeing where the puck is  going if you're driving a truck today  you know it's coming  you've heard it somebody told you at a  bus stop at a truck stop over dinner  somebody brought up this theory so  either you take it seriously and you  start educating yourself or you don't  like that's the game nobody's going to  fix that nobody can help you with that  that's life and that's the historic  nature of human beings forever  so just because we're now living and  it's our turn to go through something  this is always happened right it's  happening faster okay great so just  [Music]